[Musica]
immaginiamo di avere un secchio come
questo qui che vedete davanti a me la
società una città un quartiere sono
proprio come questo secchio allora
interno convivono il bene e il male come
dentro il secchio possiamo trovare
l'acqua pulita come l'acqua sporca
immaginiamo che un ragazzo sia come una
spugna e Cosa succede se immergiamo una
spugna dentro a questo secchio
la spugna assorbe tutto
indistintamente acqua pulita e acqua
sporca bene e male e poi come farà a
dividerli difficile senza gli strumenti
adatti queste parole non sono mie e
questa storia che sto per raccontarvi
non è la mia storia ma durante il
periodo covid in cui il carcere era un
luogo ancora più chiuso del solito
alcuni degli studenti detenuti presso
l'alta sicurezza del carcere di Milano
opera hanno scritto e messo in scena uno
spettacolo teatrale che Paragona il
ruolo della scuola all'interno del
carcere al difficile ma Fruttuoso
percorso dello schiavo liberato che esce
dalla caverna nel mito di Platone
inizialmente accecato dalla luce del
sole dopo aver visto la verità
rischierebbe però di essere ucciso Se
tornassi indietro per convincere i suoi
compagni a intraprendere la stessa
impresa
l'istruzione è un diritto ed è un
diritto di tutti che nemmeno le persone
detenute dovrebbero perdere Infatti
essere in prigione significa perdere il
proprio diritto alla libertà di
movimento Tuttavia insieme a questo
spesso si perdono altri diritti meno
appariscenti a cui magari non facciamo
caso come il diritto alla salute il
diritto all'affettività e anche appunto
il diritto all'istruzione ancora più
importante se crediamo che la scuola
possa avere un ruolo nel formare
coscienze critiche e consapevoli capaci
di operare scelte migliori per noi e per
la società che ci circonda Io credo
fortemente che la scuola possa avere
questo potere e per questo motivo dal
2018 faccio parte di un progetto
dell'università Statale di Milano
progetto carcere
che si occupa proprio di garantire
l'esigibilità al diritto allo studio
delle persone detenute presso le carceri
Lombarde e in particolare quelle
milanesi di Opera e di Bollate da quasi
cinque anni quindi circa una volta a
settimana entro in carcere incontro i
nostri studenti scelgo insieme a loro
gli esami che vogliono sostenere porti
loro i libri di cui hanno bisogno e
offro sostegno allo studio quando è
necessario ogni volta che parlo di
questa esperienza la prima domanda che
mi viene fatta è perché Perché lo fai Ma
sei proprio sicura
E poi cosa abbia destato in me questo
strano interesse per il carcere e la
volontà di aiutare gli altri in questo
modo a dire il vero a portarmi in
carcere per la prima volta è stata la
curiosità
a farmi entrare per la prima volta in
questo mondo sconosciuto è proprio il
fatto che rimanga sconosciuto per la
maggior parte delle persone Infatti si
dice il primo obiettivo del carcere
Dovrebbe essere quello di permettere la
risocializzazione di quelle persone che
per un periodo di tempo Più o meno lungo
rimangono in custodia dello Stato
a essere onesti il sistema attuale
funziona un po' al contrario ovvero come
potentissima barriera di separazione tra
società civile e popolazione carceraria
che rimanere chiusa in luoghi lugubri
molto spesso lontani dai centri
cittadini e appunto irraggiungibili alla
vista dei più Questo è anche il motivo
per cui io sento l'urgenza di parlare di
questo argomento qui con voi adesso e
tutte le volte che ne ho l'occasione lo
sanno bene i miei amici e i miei
genitori qui in sala costantemente
sottoposti alle mie storie sulla
prigione lo so Siete esperti anche voi
ormai Però farlo in quanto tutor
universitaria non solo mi permette di
osservare questo mondo dall'interno ma
di farlo da un punto di vista
privilegiato
ovvero confrontandomi con quelle persone
che ogni volta mi dimostrano quanto
valore perderemmo se ci accontentassimo
di credere che il carcere sia davvero
solo un contenitore per crimini e
criminali da tenere ben lontano e
separato da quel noi di cui spesso
parliamo quando diciamo un mondo per noi
Infatti stiamo per scontato che dietro a
questo Noi ci stiano un po' tutti La
verità è che quando Pensiamo ad un mondo
per noi chi sono davvero quei noi che
riteniamo meritevoli di vivere in un
mondo più giusto più felice più
sostenibile quando diciamo noi non
intendiamo affatto tutti ma molte
categorie sono spesso dimenticate o
addirittura rimosse e a tracciare la
linea tra degni e non degni molto spesso
è proprio l'istruzione
quell'istruzione che al contrario
dovrebbe garantire a tutti e
democraticamente gli strumenti necessari
per affrontare problemi complessi come
quello di immaginare il mondo in cui
vorremmo vivere la prima volta sono
entrato in carcere perché ero curiosa
adesso ogni volta ci entro perché so che
quello che ricevo in questi luoghi è
immensamente di più di quello che potrò
mai dare io sono una laureanda
magistrale in scienze filosofiche E come
ha scritto Giuseppe Ferraro che a lungo
si è occupato di istruzione e
marginalità se la filosofia vuole
davvero occuparsi di questioni ultime
dovrebbe andare a cercare le sue
risposte proprio in questi luoghi
ritenuti ultimi Ecco Oggi tutti insieme
insieme a voi vorrei che facessimo un
passo
verso questi luoghi ultimi vorrei che
non fossimo noi la società civile
istruita e perché no privilegiata a
rappresentare i compagni di prigionia di
quello schiavo di Platone di cui
parlavamo all'inizio non vorrei Quindi
che ci facessimo accecare dalla facile
convinzione che ci ha commesso un reato
si è riducibile solo e soltanto a questo
stesso reato e quindi cattivo
pericoloso delinquente
al contrario vorrei che proprio come lo
schiavo ci sforzassimo anche facendo
fatica con gli occhi che bruciano per
provare a scorgere quel potenziale
Lucente che queste persone hanno da
offrirci
Guido uno studente molto brillante a cui
piace essere chiamato per nome perché è
una cosa che in carcere non capita
spesso una volta mi ha detto diciamo
sempre che le carceri sono sovraffollate
è vero È verissimo è un grande problema
e lo sappiamo tutti tuttavia quello di
cui spesso non ci accorgiamo è che le
carceri funzionano un po' come grandi
magazzini di scatole vuote gli spazi
sono oberati ma dentro non vi si trova
nulla
forse grazie alla scuola e alla cultura
possiamo fare in modo che le carceri non
rimangano solo dei magazzini di scatole
vuote ma possiamo provare a riempirle di
sapere di relazioni umane positive e
fruttuose e perché no Se siamo fortunati
Magari anche di quei pregiudizi che
vorremmo lasciare dentro una volta
usciti per portare fuori insieme a noi
la consapevolezza che per pensare ad un
mondo più giusto più sostenibile e più
felice anche in un luogo insolito come
questo come il carcere possiamo trovare
preziosissime risorse
[Applauso]
[Musica]